um so annie you're one of my favorite
reporters
in the world in terms of just seeing
what's out there
uh and i can sense the pain
um in in your voice when you think about
what is going on out there
where it's your job to actually talk to
people
and make sense of the the data so
as an economics reporter right now how
do you
figure out just how bad the damage is
it's um it's pretty hard this is a
really unusual recession
um it happened really fast it was this
kind of
induced recession for public health
reasons
so we had this kind of soft i don't want
to call it a lockdown because we never
really locked down
but this sort of withdrawal of business
activity that was driven
not by the federal government but by
state and local governments and
and really largely by people themselves
being like i don't want covid
i don't want to spread covid i'm going
to stay home
and and you had a pretty impressive i
was
i was pleasantly surprised at the cares
act how big it was and
how aggressive it was um but we
proceeded to do nothing on the public
health front
um at a federal level and you know we're
nearing 200 000 people dead
and now we've had this really dramatic
withdrawal of support
so ppp is over while businesses are
still
struggling um the 600 boost
is gone in ui so that's taking
i believe it's like 60 billion dollars
out of the economy every month and
that's
from tends to be disproportionately
lower income families who are quite
likely to spend it
and so i feel like we're a little bit in
that um
in that circumstance where like you know
the coyote runs off of the cliff and
just is suspended in
air for a minute um that's august
yeah that was that was august and i feel
like gravity is now going to kick in
yeah and we still you know we have these
eviction moratoria
we've not seen um a ton of evidence of a
sharp decline in consumer spending but
that's certainly coming
and so it's pretty hard but you talk to
people and
people are really frightened and
things are really bad and we are seeing
exactly what everybody thought which is
mass business failure
and that mass business failure is going
to be the thing that will turn this into
something like a depression
because like when your business shuts
down for no good reason
your employees get laid off you go
through a bankruptcy process
um you know you have some wealth effect
and it has that that
that knock-on effect and so i'm i'm
really worried this is this is
really bad and i think it's going to
take quite some
time to claw our way out of this um
and i think other countries have
certainly done better on the health
front
i think that they've also done better on
the econ front um and
the fact that we never really got
control of the virus is is
you know culprit it is the alpha and
omega of why everything is terrible at
the moment
yeah you reference the fact that people
are going to make the choices they make
and it's one of the things i find so
frustrating about some of the
discussions that if
a governor or the feds
uh make a decision about businesses in a
locality
or travel restrictions or the the lack
thereof
there are still going to be millions of
americans who just look up and say you
know what
i don't think i am going to take that
trip i don't think i am going to go to
that restaurant i don't think i am
necessarily
going to uh hit the bar
the movie theater or whatnot uh and and
so that
set of choices will just have these long
lasting ripple effects for as long as
the virus
is out of control uh and as someone
who's run businesses myself
you know right now your appetite for
uh or risk expansion
expenses is so negative right now
that i can see how that's just going to
cascade through the economy when people
start thinking okay like i've given it a
little bit of time and now i'm going to
have to actually start making
the difficult decisions the layoffs the
adjustments
yeah i think that that's right um you
know if you just
take the kind of capital investment
portion of the economy
the hit there alone is probably enough
to
reduce output over a course of of years
um how are businesses supposed to to
plan
for the future if the virus is still
spreading and schools are still
still shut down and everybody's still
really afraid of this and
and you know now we're coming into flu
season and people are going to be
indoors
um it's it's a really impossible
situation that we've put people in
and you know and and i think that this
is um
the catastrophe is being born on the
back of service workers low-income
workers in general
um you know and in terms of the the
really negative stuff on the horizon
we knew that there was going to be huge
problems with state and local spending
lo and behold like we're starting to see
those layoffs and those pay cuts come
through
um so that's just buying us a longer
recession and
it's really frustrating because i think
a lot of the issues here are amenable to
policy solutions
and we are not both both congress and
the white house are just electing not to
not to rely on those solutions um and
this is this is going to be
this is so bad and i felt like we had
learned some
lessons from the great recession in
terms of just spending your way out of
it and just not stopping until
you you saw wage growth down in the
bottom of the income spectrum
and um and employment growth kind of
across
across educational bands and in
different racial groups and all over the
country and
you know it's just we we didn't really
learn those lessons um and
and so this is this is a real it's a
real mess
um and again i think that that the data
is not caught up to people's lived
experience just in terms of how bad this
is right now
um one of the stats that i cited in my
dnc speech which i think really
is very powerful and telling is that
approximately 42 percent of the jobs
that are being lost right now will not
return
yes and i one reason why i hit that
point so hard is that
there are a lot of people i think that
are waiting for things to quote unquote
go back to normal
yeah and we need to get used to the fact
that what we're seeing right now is
actually
closer to the whatever new normal is
going to be
yeah absolutely so i mean i feel like um
one thing that is happening is that the
the kind of critical number for congress
um for the federal government is not
that sort of top line how much money are
you spending
right it's it's this gap it's the gap
between
what the economy could be doing um
absent the pandemic and the shutdowns
um and and what it is doing and you need
the federal government to fill that hole
however big the whole is right like this
is the whole
notion of keynesian stimulus and so
you know so how so how big is the whole
annie like how big
how much do you think what do you think
they should be uh filling yeah i don't
think that
three trillion which is um the number
that they
they settled on in the heroes act is is
that far off
even though they've already spent the
2.2 trillion in the cares act
it doesn't matter they need to spend
whatever it is
um will will bring that that that
overall number up
and they can they can do it in the most
effective way possible
so so um we have really good
measurements of this thing called the
fiscal multiplier
which is for every dollar of deficit
spending how much more does that dollar
get spent in the economy or how big is
the impact of it
i love it you do something like tax cuts
it's a pretty small impact
you do something like sending people
with no cash cash and it's a really big
impact so unemployment insurance is one
of the most effective ways to do this
um just sending people cash is a great
way to do it
things like payroll tax holidays are
really bad and inefficient
way to do it so you need the number to
be really big and you want it to be
weighted to things that are heavily
effective at fighting a recession
and instead congress is just like
sitting on their hands and not doing
anything
and and we are going to see evictions we
are going to see job losses we are going
to see business closures we are already
seeing them
this is happening and and we know why
it's happening and we are seeing it
happen in real time
and the time that they needed to start
passing the stimulus was like months ago
not not now and we still don't have the
bill
and and it's creating tremendous
uncertainty as you point out
because what what what business owner is
going to be investing right now who is
sure of the future
if the future is involving this much
unnecessary death and
and economic destruction yeah the the
i can sense your frustration i'm
frustrated so many people listening to
this too
have uh become just fed up with our
leaders leaders inability to act and do
the basics
uh and there's a pandemic which we are
handling terribly uh i think that that's
pretty clear to most everyone
um and then there's the compounded
economic damage which we're also
handling terribly and that like these
two things together they
they make people so um
distraught i mean i'm distraught and
angry
over this state of affairs um
and your side too i mean i read your
work and i i can feel like there is this
beating heart of an agenda behind um the
urgency you're trying to to heighten
over
the level of economic distress yeah
absolutely
um this is this is a crisis um
and i have some i don't know
why um this sense that it is a crisis
and we should be acting with absolute
urgency is not necessarily something
that that all
people in the political system share i
certainly think that many
do and are screaming their heads off and
banging their heads against the wall
to try to get things done but i do think
that it's an argument for
having more automatic stabilizers and
taking
responsibility out of the hands of
congress which is very very broken
institution i also i mean i have a
theory
that i it's just a theory um and i have
no evidence for this
but this recession the pain of this
recession has been so concentrated among
lower income workers
who tend to be more disenfranchised in
our political process
we've already seen wealth recover to
roughly where it was
before the recession and the pandemic
and just a lot of the economic pain
hasn't been focused up at the top
and i do worry that that's maybe part of
what's going on here is you know the
unemployment rate for people who were
making a lot of money before
highly educated is actually not that
high it's gone up but but
but um it's been much much much much
higher for kind of
service workers um workers who might
happen to have less education
um or who might have been sort of
marginalized in the economy for a bunch
of other reasons to begin with
um and i feel like you know for high
income folks this has now
become about the issue of what do you do
with your kids which is a really really
stressful and important issue but um the
disproportionate burden
of of the health crisis and the economic
crisis is is really being
born by the people with the least
capacity to manage it
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode